So, I am Jason McGee and I am CTO for IBM Cloud platform. I'm Chris Nguyen, I'm
CEO and Co-founder of LogDNA. So great to be here with you Chris, I think we just
got a chance to talk about our
partnership and what we're doing. Why
don't you kick off with you know tell us
a little bit about LogDNA and what you
guys do, and then we'll talk about kind
of our partnership together. Absolutely,
thanks for having me this is a super fun
moment. LogDNA, we help developers and
engineers, DevOps teams monitoring and debug
their production issues. We aggregate all
the logs, whether it's from servers or OS
and platforms and we put into a powerful
platform that gives you
full visibility into your infrastructure
which is pretty fun. That's great, yeah so,
you know at IBM Cloud we're
trying to build this platform for
developers, and logging and
observability are so important for
developer productivity, and so you and I
started work together a few years ago to
kind of combine the best of what you
guys were doing and bring it to the IBM
Cloud platform. It's been really
interesting to me when you tell me a
little bit about like the growth that
you guys have seen over the last
year. It's been awesome, like we,
I love being a customer of IKS and we see the scale and the
flexibility that it made perfect sense
when we met two years ago, your world and
our world goes hand-in-hand. Right.
And it's nice, we we were big
believers in multicloud, we're big
believers in Kubernetes, and it's nice
that the bets we made two years ago
actually paid off, and it's actually the
future what we think about together.
Right. I think what was nice is the
simplicity of IBM Cloud match our
simplicity of what we think about simple
is also powerful from a usability
perspective, from a scale, from a search,
and it's very seamless. That's the best
part, is the key to developers, and IBM Cloud
with the power of LogDNA, so it's a
great win-win scenario. Yeah, I mean, so
let's talk about, kind of you as a client
of IBM Cloud, you know one of the
things that attracted me to LogDNA was
really two things. One was this
incredible user experience that you guys
have built around developer need for
understanding their environments, and two,
especially two or three years ago, very
forward-looking on, kubernetes as a
platform for running things.
So, you know what's worked well for you on
IBM Cloud? What, do you know, what do you like
about it?
I think simplicity to scale. So when we
think about scale we we do a lot, and
again I don't know full information but
we do a lot, and we have a pretty lean
team that could manage that and scale.
So, I think nowadays with the power of
kubernetes you don't have to maintain it
as much, right. So, there's like, I
think you mentioned that 70/30 rule,
in the past you know 70% is is spent
on maintaining infrastructure, it's flipped
now, right, and we love that. So it allowed
us to deploy LogDNA on your
infrastructure, pretty efficiently, and
from a customer perspective it's easy to
use and it matches with the best out
there, so we love it and we're super
proud to be to call ourselves customers.
Yeah, and one of the things I think is
really interesting is that they take logging
as a use case. It's not maybe what
people typically think of with
kubernetes, you know, it's very
data-intensive, lots of information, high
ingest rates on logs coming in, a lot of
processing, not where people really
started with kubernetes. Any struggles
they're like..? No. Do you feel that like, you
know, I'm doing something on the edge or
you know, did it..? I think we always had
the foresight of the volume of days
growing exponentially. So when you think
about that, we had to think about
building a platform that's able to
ingest that well and store and search
it. The second is because of the
complexity, we knew the complexity
because of DevOps, containers, kubernetes,
it's gonna be complex and the data is going to be
fragmented. So how do we make it simple,
and I think our user experience is
always magical, and it should always feel
that way. Right. And the third, was like
one size does not always fit all, so how do you
capture the right platform for
developers, versus DevOps, versus security,
and that is hard to do, and it was a lot
of foresight we did, I think we
just hit our four-year birthday and we
had that first foresight of like it
should be a beautiful product and less
is more. So you're up and running with
kubernetes with two command lines which
is pretty quick. Right. And you tested it.
Yeah. Which is awesome and that's how it
should always feel like, you have other
things to focus on your priorities, and us
handling the infrastructure monitoring
aspect, observability, should be our core
focus,
that's the benefit of IBM customers. Yeah,
so let's talk about our partnership a
little bit, so logging it plays an
important role for IBM. You know you are
the embedded logging solution within our
cloud. Yes. And you know I think the you
and I have done a lot of work together
to try to make that a seamless
experience for our users, our joint users.
You know one of the ways that I
tried to push our partnership is IBM
being a client of yours as well. Correct.
We have this kind of joint relationship
which I think is really powerful, and we
use LogDNA tremendously within the
cloud team, and in other parts of IBM to run our own systems. Yes.
Right. And I think that's taught us a lot
about you know how to operate at scale,
you've pushed kubernetes service hard
which has been good as well. Talk
to me a little bit about kind of the
partnership angle and kind of how its
benefited you guys. It's such a win-win
scenario, So one, we're customers of IBM
Cloud.
Second, we get to embed OEM, our product to
your customer base. Right. And your
customers happens in two folds, it's
your customer base that you have but also
IBM is their own customer. Right. And it's
such an honor when we see
scale and that's the word that resonates
a lot, and the reason why you have
scale is customers that hit Watson uses
us, Weather Channel uses us
and that's a lot of logs, right,
and it's being able to handle that infra
which just talks about so much of like
enterprise ready product. Yeah, right. Not
just for IBM, but for IBM's customers as
well and just it doesn't get more
confidence there versus the other
options that were out there. Yeah, one of
my personal favorite moments is when I
was at the Masters last year and walking
through the Operations Center that IBM
runs to run that event and and seeing
the team there on the ground who I'd
never met using LogDNA using IBM Cloud
and kind of leveraging that is how they
ran that event and all on their own, self
service, they just consumed the platform.
That's amazing, that's what we're seeing a
lot of,  just internal teams using it just
because it's easy if you're up and
running within minutes. Yeah. And that's
how it should always be, but also the
data that you're capturing and the
value of sending alerts. It's a lot of
flexibility that's we think for first
and foremost of
our product and it jointly collaborates pretty
well. Yeah, so what's next? What do
is a big thing that you think
you guys are focused on next that we can
go do together? I think when we talk
about like OpenShift is a great
opportunit,y we talked about Cloud
Paks is a great opportunity, and it's
nice that the technology, our technology is
aligned, super aligned with with your future
path and it comes down to execution. I
think being a lean team we get to
focus on what matters most, but most
importantly our core DNA has always been
developers, and it's what do developers
want, how do they get up to speed, and how
do you just get them hooked so that we
can land and expand over time. Yeah. That's a
new movement that we both share together
which is amazing. Yeah, I love
the lean team. I remember when we first
met and you know I have this really
small focused team and
the amount that, I
think we all lose sight sometimes of you
know with cloud, with public cloud, with
technologies like kubernetes, but with
all these things we were so used to
talking about we lose sight of like
how much people are able to accomplish
with small teams using those platforms.
It was awesome, a great communication between
the teams. It was just a vote of
confidence both ways because the fact
that IBM was forward thinking to say who
do we partner with, and also the fact
that we were able to showcase our
technology from scale as one perspective,
flexible deployment, but I also love that
we're fully compliant across the board.
Yeah. It's PCI, GDPR, SOC 2, HIPAA,
we were ready. Yeah. And then it doesn't
get better alignment then having the
right overlap. Especially with IBM's
kind of focused customer base absolutely
the industries that we're in like that
was really critical that that layer of
the platform which can contain a
lot of sensitive data
met those requirements and that was really
key for us. Right. And I think we get to
collaborate of what our future, our
UI/UX looks like. Right. I look forward to
how do you create predictive graphs, so
instead of teams walking in setting up
their own graphs if we know it's kubernetes
here's a five graphs you need
to know and where do you want
the alerts being sent. So, we always
think about building those magical moments
and this should feel magical when developers use us. Yeah, well look
Chris, I really appreciate the
partnership that we've had. I'm excited
for what we're doing. I think LogDNA has
really proven
to be a powerful platform for our
customers and I'm excited for
us to continue to collaborate together.
Well thanks for collaborating and we're just
getting started,
that's the best part. Great, and for everybody
else you know go check out LogDNA on logdna.com, or come to IBM Cloud
and check out the offerings that we
have there. Thank you very much. Thank you.